[Music]
i'm comedian ryan sickler and this is
how i do a maryland crab beast so if you
can't catch them live then the next best
thing to do is get them at the best
place you can in the country jimmy's
famous seafood in baltimore best crabs
and crab cakes in the country best
seafood for my money
so in maryland we steam crabs we don't
boil them and ruin them louisiana
all right and what you steam them with
is cheap beer the cheaper the better all
right you want to put a couple beers in
with some water equal parts mix it up if
you like you can put a little vinegar in
to sweeten it up we're going to go ahead
and do that just a little
whoopsie while that's boiling we're
going to set the crabs up if you got a
live crab that's how you hold a crab
right there you don't hold a crab like
this because crabs can reach right in
there and bite the [ __ ] out of you all
right you hold it there that's how you
hold a crab it can't get you from that
point these are dead so i don't have to
worry about it and you're going to layer
them all the way around in your pocket
now jimmy's includes mallets their own
seasoning that's some great stuff right
there and what you're going gonna do is
every time you get a layer of crab you
season that's how we're doing it these
are nice and heavy they always are from
jimmy
now these are ready to steam we're gonna
put the lid on we're gonna reheat them
30 minutes and boom we're gonna have a
crab piece
that's the smell of my childhood right
there all right there they are they're
done take a look at those
[Music]
that's how it's done y'all now get out
there and have yourself a feast
[Music]
you